china causa preocupación por un rebrote
de covid unas semanas después de que el
país asiático levantara su estricta
política covid cero luego de casi tres
años se ha registrado una ola de casos
nuevos a pesar que se registran imágenes
como estas en la provincia de hebei
Hasta el momento las autoridades chinas
Solo han informado sobre dos muertes por
coronavirus en los últimos días Estados
Unidos ha pedido que se informe
realmente sobre lo que está sucediendo
es muy importante que todos los países
incluidos china se centran en vacunar a
las personas que las pruebas y los
tratamientos estén disponibles y más aún
que la información sobre lo que está
pasando se ha compartido con el mundo
la política covid cero eliminada el 7 de
diciembre de 2022 incluía largos
periodos de cuarentenas constantes
pruebas pcr y fuertes restricciones para
entrar y salir del país con el
levantamiento el gobierno también
anunció el cambio en Los criterios sobre
muertes de covid
Ahora solo aquellos que mueran
directamente por insuficiencia
respiratoria a causa del virus serán
contados dentro de las estadísticas del
covid la OMS expresó su preocupación y
pidió que se notifiquen todos los casos
a lo que china se defiende desde el
estallido de la epidemia china siempre
ha publicado información sobre la
epidemia de manera oportuna abierta y
transparente y ha mantenido actualizada
a la Organización Mundial de la Salud
sobre la situación de la epidemia por su
parte Estados Unidos ha ofrecido ayudar
a China con vacunas y se espera que
Anthony blinquen viaje a Pekín a
principios de 2023